when rosma Manta was the first lady of
Malaysia she was heavily criticized for
her lavish lifestyle from designer
handbags to expensive jewelry but the
true extent of her taste for the Finer
Things in life only became clear when
her husband najib razak lost an election
in 2018.
after an investigation into allegations
of corruption the couple were eventually
charged police seized hundreds of boxes
of jewelry Handbags and cash valued at
more than a quarter of a billion dollars
on Thursday she was convicted of
soliciting a bribe of nearly 42 million
dollars and accepting one and a half
million to help a company secure a
project to build solar panels for
schools
she's been sentenced to 10 years in
prison and fined 216 million dollars but
remains on bail pending her appeal
yes we have given notice of appeal
the appeal
the refined and the jail centers has
been suspended
all right has been suspended and she is
released on a earlier bill
enforced by Court
so our client thank God he's able to go
back home
and be with the family tonight
just last week her husband began serving
a 12-year prison term after losing his
final appeal in one of several
corruption trials
the U.S justice department alleges four
and a half billion dollars were stolen
from the Malaysian State investment fund
one MDB and that around a billion
dollars from that went to najib
prosecutors also said some of the money
financed a Hollywood Blockbuster The
Wolf of Wall Street although the charges
against the production company were
later dropped the then U.S attorney
general had described the case as
kleptocracy at its worst
the Scandal played a part in the defeat
of the governing party amno in 2018.
this is not the only lawsuit against
Ross Mar Manzo she faces 17 other
charges of money laundering and tax
evasion for illegally receiving more
than one and a half million dollars in a
separate case which means her legal
troubles are far from Over Florence
Louis Al Jazeera Kuala Lumpur